clément weill-raynal de patrick dils a
déjà passé 14 ans en prison l'avocat
général de la cour de cassation demande
son maintien en détention pardon
jusqu'au deuxième procès la justice
revient sur ses décisions mais
apparemment revient lentement
oui effectivement et on pourrait presque
s'étonner que l'avocat général se soient
déclarés à la fois favorable à la
révision du procès tout en recommandant
le maintien en détention de patrick dils
alors il faut savoir que l'avocat
général a justifié cette demande en
indiquant que la remise en liberté d'une
personne condamnée à perpétuité serait
sans précédent dans les annales de la
justice et d'une certaine manière
l'avocat général a raison de son point
de vue car il ne fait qu'exprimer que
reconnaître à sa manière qui est celle
de l'accusation
le caractère exceptionnel sans précédent
de la sphère 10 parce que sans préjuger
de la décision qui va intervenir le 3
avril prochain
il n'est pas trop hasardeux d'affirmer
que désormais plus rien ne s'oppose à la
révision du procès on voit pas très bien
comment la cour de cassation pourrait
refuser ce qui a été demandé par
l'avocat général alors bien entendu
révision ne signifie pas un acquittement
automatique
cela veut simplement dire qu'il y aura
un nouveau procès mais tout de même tout
même la cour de cassation vous le disiez
a pris d'infinies précautions en
avançant très lentement
si elle accorde cette révision c'est
parce qu'elle sera forcé de reconnaître
qu'il y a un énorme problème dans le
dossier et si patrick dils venait à être
acquitté
il s'agirait de la plus gigantesque
erreur judiciaire depuis au moins un
siècle